are all of your memories real did
everything happen the way you remember
it
what if somebody filled your brain with
memories that aren't yours would you be
able to tell the difference between
what's real and what's not
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could upload fake memories
into our brains a memory is made in
three major steps encoding information
storing it and then retrieving it and it
all happens here your brain has
approximately 100 billion neurons all
passing signals back and forth through a
complex network of 1,000 trillion
synaptic connections your memories
aren't tucked away in one specific place
in your brain instead they're kept in
different groups of neurons which are
called engrams and there are a few ways
to hack them in 2016
researchers at MIT implanted a false
memory into a mouse they did it with the
help of a technique called optogenetics
basically they genetically engineered
mice to have a gene that responds to
light and then they fired lasers to
stimulate that gene but you don't need
to undergo any genetic engineering to
have false memories it's relatively easy
to manipulate your brain into thinking
it's storing information it doesn't
actually have memories of traumatic
events can be especially vulnerable to
outside influences there are cases of
people remembering being abducted by
aliens when in reality they weren't
other people remembered being present at
satanic rituals where humans were
sacrificed even though they weren't all
these people can thank hypnotherapists
and their ability to plant false
memories using only the power of
suggestion
you see memories are not really a
reality there's something that can be
created molded and influenced that's why
I witnesses aren't too reliable when it
comes to describing the details of a
crime scene for example in one study
test subjects were shown footage of car
accidents and 26 percent of them
remembered seeing a bus despite there
not being any bus in the footage we are
having false memories fed to our brains
on a daily basis through social media
and news with the studies currently
underway it's possible that a more
direct in brain connection could be made
and used to manipulate and create
memories if that happens who would make
the call on uploading false memories
would the person receiving them be aware
of what was happening and what if they
weren't maybe we could use these kinds
of memory implants to reformed criminals
faster or to help make a dying person's
final days better for them would we make
businesses that implant fake vacations
or rewrite the memories of some
traumatic events
someone's suffering from post-traumatic
stress disorder could have their memory
wiped clean and start their life again
we could overwrite the memories of abuse
or upload memories that would help a
person to cope with a difficult
situation from their past and it would
all seem so real that they might never
know it wasn't in the future we could
implant memories that form a decent
moral code in everyone on the planet and
create a respectful society free of
crime on the other hand this could go
very wrong in so many ways the
technology could be used to alter the
neurons in a person's brain making them
feel something they really don't or
think they did something they actually
didn't would you trust your medical
professional if you required a memory
implant personally I would rather upload
my brain to the cloud and become
digitally immortal but before uploading
myself into the cloud I'd have to make
sure it's absolutely safe our friends at
Nord VPN the sponsors of this episode
know everything there is to know about
virtual security Nord VPN keeps your
browsing history safe by providing you
with a Virtual Private Network thanks to
Nord VPN no bad guys can get their
grubby little hands on your data your
passwords or your personal information
and while keeping your network safe Nord
VPN also gives you an unlimited web
browsing experience ever been surfing
YouTube and you suddenly can't watch a
video because it's not available in your
country
well Nord VPN masks your IP address
giving the illusion that you're in any
country in the world virtually speaking
we really like it here at what if you
can get your own VPN to go to Nord VPN
comm slash what if and use the coupon
code what if that's one word to get 70%
off a three year plan plus one month
free
okay now I'm ready to upload my brain
into the cloud the upload begins in
three two one
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]